today I want to talk about three
principles that changed my life and
these learnings are influenced by my six
years working in Consulting at McKinsey
but also my subsequent roads in industry
and in startup as a c-level executive so
welcome to another coffee break here on
my channel from learning and sticking to
water today because it is already quite
late here in Germany and without further
Ado I want to start with the first
principle and this is about how to
achieve Financial Freedom but I must
warn you because the truth what I'm
going to share is maybe quite different
from what you are expecting many people
seem to believe that saving is the best
way to Achieve Financial Freedom and I
also myself have talked about the
importance of saving in the past I will
link some videos about this above there
but what does Financial Freedom really
mean and surely there are different
definitions out there what I like is the
definition that is used by the fire
movement fire stands for financial
Independence retire early it's a group
of people who set themselves the goal to
not work throughout the whole working
life but at some point stop working and
be able to live just from your capital
and the capital gains and this is
exactly the definition I want to adopt
for this video Financial Independence
means that you don't need to work
anymore and you can live purely on your
capital gains the what would it really
take to Achieve Financial Independence
and one rule commonly applied in the
personal finance Community is the four
percent Rule and this means that on
average if you have your Capital
invested in a mix of stocks and bonds
you can expect that you can achieve a
four percent pre-tax return in
perpetuity more or less without
bankrupting your capital from this four
percent you deduct about 25 percent as
capital gains tax and as a commonly
applied for instance in Germany and
other countries you will end up with
about three percent post-tax returns
that you can expect on your Capital this
is of course a simplified calculation
but one that might be quite helpful here
so if you work with some such a three
percent rule what is the capital that
you need in order to be financially
dependent of course the number differs
for everyone in my simple mind I'd say
if you're 4 million euro 4 million
dollar doesn't matter that much in the
current euro dollar parity if a 4
million euro invested and apply three
percent to that that means that you have
actually a net disposable income after
tax of 120
000 euro per year or 10 000 euro per
month so 10 000 euro per month for your
free disposal I'd say most people would
say that yes they would consider
themselves financially independent if
they achieved this with this rule of
thumb of three percent you can calculate
for yourself what your target number
would be but let's for the sake of this
argument stick with the 4 million euro
so what do you need for that what does
it take to have four million euros saved
at some time well let's imagine there's
someone who earns on average 100
000 Euros per per year gross before tax
based on any employment on average
throughout their working life of 40
years and arguably if you were able to
do that you are surely one of the more
successful people right I'd argue it's
quite difficult on average over a period
of 40 years to earn such a high profile
salary even if you work in a high-paced
careers in Consulting Banking and so on
why because of course the first years
you will earn less because you're just a
junior then maybe there's a certain
period in your life where you have
decided salaries but then many people
also during the course of their career
at some point also start earning less
again because maybe also these fast
paced types of jobs are not right for
them this is my perspective let me know
what you think about this in the
comments but if you stick with these
numbers so 40 years 100 000 euro per
year this means that after 40 years you
will have earned 4 million euro right so
these are more or less your lifetime
earnings for someone working in a
fast-paced high profile career so
basically on this you can see that yes
it is possible to have 4 million euros
lifetime earnings but the problem of
course is that this is before tax before
Social Security contributions this can
easily consume half of this amount and
then you need to pay for rent for living
expenses for the tuition of your kids so
even if you are such a high earner
saving 4 million euro will be extremely
difficult if you follow a common career
path even in one of these high profile
careers I talk so often about on this
channel and this is exactly the first
key Insight the first implication I want
to share with you in this video and this
is something that took me quite a lot of
time to figure this out but this means
that if you want to truly Achieve
Financial Independence it is a very very
very difficult to do this based on a
regular employment based on a regular
job again even if you do work for such a
high-paced career of course there are
some positions where this is possible of
course there are some people who achieve
maybe income writing a partner a senior
partner Rank and are able to keep such a
role throughout their professional life
of course these people will be able to
achieve these types of financial goals
but of course these are only a very
small minority of people and I think you
would not be wise to follow a strategy
that this would be exactly the type of
position that you will find yourself in
at some point so what is the learning
from that well if at some point you do
want to improve your life to the better
you do want to Achieve Financial Freedom
following this definition which of
course might not be the goal of everyone
of course maybe you might have another
mission that is completely fine for you
as well you need to do to some extent
something out of the ordinary you need
to look into entrepreneurship into
developing your side projects doing
something next to your regular job
otherwise just mathematically it's
almost impossible to achieve this the
next principle I got a lot out of for my
personal life is about avoiding the
tyranny of the r and this is from a book
I picked up as a teenager it's from Jim
Collins bestseller built to last a book
I can very much recommend there's a link
to it in the video description for free
to pick it up yourself and one of the
things that Jim Collins describes here
is that successful people are able to
avoid exactly that the tyranny of the
ore the tyranny of new or describes a
belief system that many people think
that things can either be a or b but not
the same time it can either be like this
or like that but having both things at
the same time doing both things at the
same time both things being true at the
same time is not possible this is a
contradiction that many people have in
their head and there are lots of
examples for that I can either be a good
person or I can climb up the corporate
letter I can either spend time with my
family or I can use the evenings to go
out for sports I can either have fun
during my time in University or I can be
a good student and write Ace all the
time either or or RR this exactly is the
tyranny of the Arts this limiting belief
that you cannot have it all that you
cannot make through several things at
the same time and how Jim Collins
described the successful people are able
to actually embrace the genius of the
end it is very often absolutely possible
to achieve many of these maybe on the
surface contradictory goals at the same
time I had claimed that all of the
things I just talked about probably it
is possible to achieve all of them
together and this is exactly a very
important mindset to adopt to some
extent maybe you could claim that also
my life I adopted exactly this mindset
by starting the YouTube channel right I
get questions all the time how is it
possible to work a full-time career and
also do all these YouTube videos well I
do think that it is possible it's about
priorities it's about wanting it setting
yourself your goals so ask this for
yourself what is your YouTube channel of
course my claim that everyone should
start a YouTube channel but what does
this mean for you where can you embrace
the G Genius of the end to enrich your
life both personally and professionally
the next principle I'd like to call
being in the right versus winning versus
winning in life and my grandmother once
asked me Heinrich do you want to be in
the right or do you want to achieve your
goals some people are obsessed with
being in the right they're literally
willing to lose all their existence they
lose their sympathy that other people
have for them to lose money just to
prove other people wrong this is such a
common theme of human behavior that the
German author Heinrich Von kleist wrote
a whole novel about it has this tragic
actor who lost his whole life his whole
existence indeed just to prove that he
was in the right it's a classic of
German literature I can very much
recommended to pick this up this way
examples for this Behavior big and small
can be witnessed almost every day people
willing to lose their sympathy just to
prove someone wrong people's viewing
each other over trivial stuff people
getting involved in heated arguments
about things that don't matter at all
people correcting each other over things
that just do not matter for sure and yes
while I do not want to claim that this
is always wrong should there some
situations where such a behavior would
be justified I would claim that very
often this type of behavior is usually
just motivated by fragile ego and
wounded pride of course there's the
natural instinct to do something against
it always take a step back ask yourself
what you actually want to achieve and
whether this really helps you to get
there so love to know that your view on
this do you agree with these principles
anything you'd like to add I trust this
will be very insightful for other people
watching this if you took any value out
of this video at all please destroy the
like button for the YouTube algorithm
subscribe big big thanks to the members
of the channel my name is Jaime I
release regular videos here on the
channel see you again next week and bye
bye